est ce que tous les êtres humains se
ressemblent non on est d'accord on fout
ne ressemble pas mamadou mamadou ne
ressemble pas à charles henri charles
henry ne ressemble pas à suresh mais
dans un même pays sur une même région
ici par exemple aux caraïbes
est-ce qu'on se ressemblent tous dites
moi cette étape est elle va fonctionner
et bien voilà tenez regardez cette photo
pour une même marque de fabrique j'ai
plusieurs modèles à vous proposer
nous avons ici des versions peau claire
des versions peau brune d'aînés droit
d'aimer plat et toute une gamme
capillaire allant du cheveu lisse aux
cheveux crépus et bien vous voyez mon
stock est très bien achalandé et bien
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter ma
famille
il y a plus de chances que je ressemble
à l'un d'entre vous dans cette salle
plutôt qu'à ma propre mère chercher là
et pourtant
où qu'on aille dans le monde
on nous proposera toujours le fast food
avec un grand m
vous aurez beau faire des dizaines des
centaines des milliers de kilomètres on
vous proposera toujours les mêmes films
les mêmes it et les mêmes centres
commerciaux avec la clim à fond et le
fast food avec le grand m
vous trouvez pas ça surprenant qu ici
aux antilles on nous vante des bonnets
non mais sincèrement vous trouvez pas ça
de ce surprenant qu'il soit plus facile
de trouver un bon restaurant japonais
plutôt qu'un matete à crabes
il n'y a pas quelque chose qui cloche
sérieusement c'est fou ça on est tous
différents et on nous sert à travers le
monde
la même soupe collective je vais vous
poser une question et j'aimerais que
vous me répondiez en votre âme et
conscience
qui parmi vous pensent qu'il peut
contribuer à la création d'un monde qui
nous ressemblent vraiment qui dans cette
salle pense qu'il peut changer le monde
super bravo à vous
alors pour ceux qui ont levé la main ce
qui va suivre va vous parler pour ceux
qui n'ont pas levé la main je me donne
comme mission de vous prouver que c'est
possible
ma conviction à moi et bien
décidément cette étape est aujourd'hui
ne va pas nous lâcher sérieusement ok
oui ma conviction parce que je sais
qu'elle vous intéresse eh bien ma
conviction c'est qu'il ne faut pas
attendre que le monde change parce que
les habitudes sont tenaces
en effet c'est beaucoup plus facile de
laisser faire mais c'est parce que nous
avons des rêves communs d'un monde
différent que de nouvelles choses
peuvent émerger
vous connaissez wise airbnb et bien ces
sites ils ont complètement bouleversé
des monopoles industriels ils ont changé
notre façon de nous déplacer et de
voyager vous voyez les entrepreneurs
change le monde et ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux la question aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que les caribéens sont eux
aussi capables de transformer le monde
c'est une question que je me suis
beaucoup posé et à laquelle aujourd'hui
j'ai répondu avec certitude
premier exemple ana julia cooper donc là
c'est la zapette ana julia cooper fin du
19e siècle sud des états unis cette
femme fait partie des anciens esclaves
les anciens esclaves viennent d'être
affranchi mais ils n'ont encore le droit
à rien à nager à cooper la première
chose qu'elle fait est bien c'est de se
battre pour apprendre à lire et à écrire
à partir du moment où elle aura appris à
lire et à écrire
elle ira consacré toute sa vie à
accompagner les anciens esclaves pour
qu'ils apprennent à lire et à écrire
parce que selon elle c'était la seule
façon pour les affranchis de réussir
leur leur nouvelle vie excusez moi vous
m'entendez là ok très bien
deuxième exemple deuxième exemple
raoul georges nicolo
savez vous que c'est grâce à lui que
vous avez sur vos postes de télévision
aujourd'hui plusieurs chaînes
les visions au lieu d'une seule ce
scientifique guadeloupéen a également
permis d'ouvrir la voie à usage civil
pour l'énergie atomique
grosso modo c'est en partie grâce à lui
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons accès à
l'électricité produite par le nucléaire
troisième exemple un barbadien shannon
clark c'est un contemporain il a à peine
30 ans pourtant sa contribution
aujourd'hui est extrêmement importante
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a créé mais
dire vu une application qui permet de
réduire le nombre de décès liés au
diabète
vous saviez vous qu aujourd'hui encore
60% des causes de dia d'aidé cause de
mortalité aux caraïbes et en amérique
latine était liée au diabète
vous vous rendez compte de ce qu'il est
en train de faire ce jeune homme
ok j'imagine que ces exemples peuvent
vous intimider vous vous dites peut-être
bon ok c'est sympa mais alors moi
franchement je trouve ça trop compliqué
et puis surtout j'ai pas cette force là
j'y arriverai pas mais s'il vous plaît
gardez en tête que tout commence par un
premier petit pas un premier nom un
premier il faut que ça change
j'ai envie de vous parler de moi alors
je vais le faire vous connaissez
l'échangeur de versailles qu'il a déjà
emprunté cet échangeur celui entre la la
route des mamelles et la rna décidément
il ya une partie de la guadeloupe qui
est pas visité en fait
ok et bien sachez que c'était moi qui
était à la tête de ses opérations là sur
le chantier
après ça j'ai fait plein de choses et
j'ai fini en dirigeant une filiale d'un
grand groupe coté au cac40
alors autant vous dire que des
responsabilités j'en avais tout le monde
me disait mais tu es un bon job c'est
super j'avais un salaire confortable et
pourtant j'ai tout lâché j'ai tout lâché
pour pouvoir aider les start-up a émergé
dans les pays jeunes pourquoi parce que
je suis convaincu qu'aujourd'hui
l'entrepreneuriat et bien c'est un
formidable levier d'anticipation pour
les peuples des pays jeunes dont font
partie bien évidemment la guadeloupe et
vous savez quoi ce qui est génial c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je vois je suis témoin de
l'excitation de la fierté de jeunes qui
sont en train de créer des projets qui
sont soutenus par des centaines de
personnes est vraiment j'ai une hâte
vous les présentez vous les présenter et
les laissez vous raconter leur histoire
les histoires je sais pas vous mais moi
j'aime beaucoup ça vous aimez ça vous
merci c'est mieux alors eh bien je vais
vous en raconter encore une pour vous
convaincre
pour ceux qui n'avaient pas levé la main
tout à l'heure pour vous convaincre
qu'il est possible de changer l'ordre
établi
et comme ici aux caraïbes la musique est
très présente
je suis sûr que ça va vous parler alors
1 2 3 on part on part coup on part en
1978 pour les plus jeunes un petit peu
d'efforts alors 1978 on est aux antilles
françaises
les loups noirs tabou combo et les
frères sicot sont des stars il joue du
combat ils sont à la mode et surtout ils
sont haïtiens
et alors ça ça a le don de mettre les
producteurs et les musiciens locaux dans
une colère monstre
tant et si bien que lors d'une réunion
secrète
tous s'accordent pour mettre en place un
embargo physique vis-à-vis des haïtiens
et toc
tous sont d'accord sauf
un irréductible antilles et il n'a pas
30 ans il est noir il a un afro et paie
une moustache recourbées vers le bas du
visage et il va se battre pour les
valeurs qu'ils ont poussé vers la
musique
pour lui il est mais hors de question de
priver les antillais d'une musique
qu'ils aiment et qui leur fait du bien
non non non et non on ne va pas isolé on
ne va pas bouder il faut au contraire
s'ouvrir encore plus créer une musique
plus forte
une musique qui parle aux antillais qui
leur fasse du bien
et puis pourquoi pas une musique qui
puisse aller au delà de nos frontières
bon sens partir de ce moment-là son
combat va devenir de créer une musique
respectueuse des traditions et
furieusement moderne
le révolutionnaire dont je vous parlais
s'appelle freddy marshall à ce moment là
c'est un des musiciens du groupe les
vikings de la guadeloupe excusez moi les
vikings de la guadeloupe quoi enfin ce
freddy marshall accompagné de pierre
edouard décimus vous commencez à avoir
un indice fait le point sur sa vision
créer un plan d'action et ensemble ils
créent le groupe kassav et ça c'est pour
vous rappeler comment ça s'écrit parce
que je pense que c'est important
ils font de ce groupe kassav alors
freddy marshall rassemble autour de lui
une équipe de musiciens et tous ensemble
ils vont créer ce son nouveau fait de
traditions et de modernité
on a des tambours du carnaval et du
tiroir betata à la guitare on à jacob
devarieux à la base georges décimus et
pour la première fois aux antilles ici
là on a des synthétiseurs et des
programmateurs qui sont utilisés les
cuivres sont là pour rendre la musique
plus exportable
tout ça ils le font en créole attendez
vous savez quoi
l'innovation qui a apporté kassav ne
s'arrêtait pas au son parce que pour eux
il était hors de question de se
présenter devant le public avec un bal
comme le voulait alors usage pour eux
c'est simple modernité égale spectacle
égale concert égale du son des effets
des corps et déco des choristes et de la
lumière points c'est ça ou rien la
carrière de kassav bat son plein et
d'album en album j'ai pas si vous avez
remarqué mais on ressent une meilleure
utilisation des instruments et puis un
hommage plus fort plus affirmée à
l'identité culturelle caribéenne
qu'elles savent ils chez kassav ils
n'ont jamais cessé de s'améliorer de
progresser en fait ils ont avancé
progressivement en tenant compte des
commentaires constructifs qu'on leur
faisait et ensuite ce qui est dingue
c'est que après les antilles françaises
où ils se sont présentés avec le premier
concert en tant que tel qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait eh bien ils sont allés en
france hexagonale
ils sont allés en afrique noire ils sont
allés au maghreb
ils sont allés en caraïbe anglophone ils
sont allés dans le pacifique
ce sont eux qui ont fait le premier
stade de france complet et très dingue
ils sont allés en russie où ils se sont
fait applaudir franchement kassav
je crois qu'on peut les applaudir annuel
j'en arrête là avec kassav
mais vous savez ça me fait super plaisir
d'avoir pu partager ça avec vous parce
que cet exemple il est super parlant il
est très parlant parce que les membres
de kassav ils sont constitués de
personnes qui me ressemble et qui vous
ressemble bref qui nous ressemble et qui
montre qu'il est possible aujourd'hui de
faire bouger les lignes
et ça c'est important et en tant que
passionné de la start up
il ya autre chose qui m'a marqué et qui
m'a frappé c'est la cohérence du
parcours de kassav avec les champions de
la start up
ils ont tout simplement appliquer les
trois principes fondamentaux qui
permettent à tout révolutionnaire va
tout changer les choses 1 une vision
forte au départ deux ils ont été ré pour
avancer progressivement en tenant compte
des réactions du public
3 ils ont parlé de ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont eu une volonté furieuse de
toucher le plus grand nombre et d'aller
au delà des frontières
florent cela dit tout à l'heure je
m'appelle magali pilou et j'ai un rêve
et ce rêve c'est que l'ensemble des
caribéens applique ces trois principes
pourquoi et bien pour s'épanouir pour
casser le statut quo parce qu'ici en
caraïbe autant qu'ailleurs il est
possible de s'exprimer et de participer
à la transformation du monde
si vous voulez en savoir un peu plus et
aller plus loin sur cette voie là on en
parle à la pause avec un immense plaisir
mais bon en attendant si vous voulez me
faire plaisir sur le plus long terme
faites quelque chose tout de suite dès
demain demain c'est férié donc ne
racontait pas que je sais pas trop quoi
qu'il faut que j'aille au travail tout
ça dès demain vous faites comme kassav
s'il vous plaît ok vous appliquez les
n'ont en fait pas de la musique pas
obligatoirement un mais fait quand même
comme kassav en appliquant les trois
princes
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes appliqué on en fait
une petite révision un fait quoi quelque
chose qui vous plaît vraiment qui vous
plaît vraiment pas qui plaît aux voisins
ou je sais pas quoi qui vous plaît
vraiment qui correspond à vos valeurs à
votre vision du monde
parce que vous savez finalement une
révolution c'est commencer par assumer
ses propres envies et commencer quelque
chose de ses mains
et puis il n'existe pas de petite idée
de petits problèmes ou de problèmes trop
futile ça c'est pas vrai alors dès
demain pour tous ceux qui avaient envie
de prendre des cours de peinture c'est
parti enfin après demain puisque c'est
férié demain écrivez aussi cette
histoire que vous avez en tête depuis
très longtemps
allez-y lâchez vous assumez votre
singularité aimez votre singularité
laissez parler votre coeur on avance sur
les révisions
le basic numéro 2 et erré en gros ça
veut dire quoi
n'ayez pas peur de la première version
non aboutie de ce que vous avez fait au
contraire ça vous donne de la matière
pour parler pour collecter du feedback
et pour proposer une version 2 encore
plus performante c'est tout bénef
soyez fiers de vos débuts regardez vos
enfants quand ils apprennent à marcher
vous êtes super content soyez content
soyez fiers de vos débuts fin des
révisions avec le point 3 parler de ce
que vous faites
bah oui ça sert à rien de faire quelque
chose et de rien faire avec parler de ce
que vous faites
rechercher tous ceux qui ont la même
sensibilité que vous et franchement
n'ayez pas peur du regard des autres
encore une fois soyez fiers
si je n'avais qu'une minute ou si je
n'avais eu qu'une minute pour vous
parler aujourd'hui
et bien ce que je vous aurais dit c'est
ce qui est écrit là d'abord c'est de ne
pas attendre que le monde change parce
que c'est à vous de faire changer si
vous ne le change et paris se passera
rien et surtout et je vous laisse
apprécier la qualité de mon créole c'est
attention merci de m'encourager un peu
avant sincèrement n'oubliez pas que ces
graines du riz café sac du oui à l'homme
était marron manioc papa excuse moi
merci